we all want to be treated fairly
especially when it comes to something as
important as a salary negotiation
but how do we get the most out of these
discussions that many of us
hate to even get into hi i'm rich
burnett for one dream
and in this episode of perspectives a
handful of experts discuss
just that how to get the most out of
negotiations
and how to make sure both sides are
satisfied with the outcome
we begin now with a thought experiment
that shows how our desire to be treated
fairly can actually act
against our own best interest enjoy
imagine that i have ten thousand dollars
to give away
and that i'm willing to give it to you
and a stranger standing next to you
if the two of you can agree on a split
i will let you propose a division of the
money to that stranger
that is you'll say to her i will keep i
will get
x percent and you will get y percent
deal the stranger will decide whether to
accept or reject your offer
if she says yes then i will give you the
money to divide
as you've agreed then neither of you
will get
but if if she says no if she says no
then neither of you will get anything
you both know that ten thousand dollars
is at stake and you both know these
rules
how much will you offer her
overwhelmingly
i find that my students in america china
and france
and elsewhere typically divide the money
evenly 50
50 and almost always their counterparts
say yes
some offer to keep 60 and give 40
percent
usually their counterparts say yes but
not always
a few propose to keep 70 and give 30
percent
some say yes but some say no
usually a couple of students propose to
keep 90
and give 10 percent more often than not
their counterparts
say no deal when i ask why the
counterparts turn down a thousand
three thousand even four thousand
dollars
their answers are invariably the same
because
it's not fair no matter how i press them
arguing the economist's point that some
money is worth more than no money
they're invariably unmoved i would
rather go hungry
than see that guy get so much they say
most laboratory versions of the
ultimatum game involve
fairly low stakes and perhaps it's not
too surprising
that people will be willing to give up a
couple of bucks to punish an unfair
allocator
what happens as the stakes rise
a 2011 paper answers this question the
paper's title gives away the answer it's
called
stakes matter in the ultimatum game the
authors of the paper conducted the game
in poor villages
in northeast india the amounts of money
the allocators were asked to divide
varied but were sometimes more than what
a typical worker in that area earned
in nine months the authors found
that when stakes were set this high the
average allocator offered the decider
just
12 percent of the pie and the
overwhelming majority of deciders
roughly 95 percent
accepted these uneven offers
do we as human beings care about
fairness
of course we do and does it feel good to
spite those who we believe have treated
us unfairly
you bet it does but as more research on
ultimatum game shows
this only matters up to a point when
dealing with an amount of money that
could have a
meaningful positive impact on their
lives and the lives of their family
members
people are willing to put spite to one
side and make choices
that most people would view as more
rational to me at least
this is a reassuring result
if you want people to say yes to your
requests you should try to make a
personal connection with them
and ideally deliver a personal
compliment before you make a request
the concept that people will tend to say
yes if they like you is very intuitive
what is surprising is just how powerful
that tendency is
and how easy it is to strike this very
deep-seated reflex in our brain
if you start a persuasive interaction
with a conversation
it might seem like chit chat small talk
but small
talk can have big consequences how was
your weekend
did you get outside for some fun in the
sun well yes peter i did
on sunny days i like to play tennis
tennis me too
my kids are learning to play so we
batted the ball around a little
a few times we even managed to play a
full game i have kids too
they like tennis as well and they're
starting to get good at serving
blah blah blah but this connection can
be enough to
trigger another one of those unconscious
reflexes
both parties in this conversation are
people who like to be outside in the sun
play tennis and have children
there's a lot of evidence that if i make
some requests after
these connections have been made after
they've been made apparent i'll be far
more likely to get a yes response
in studies of business negotiation
behaviors
the likelihood of a successful outcome
is more than tripled in some cases
when the negotiation itself is preceded
by a few minutes of conversation
if you're negotiating with very little
or no information
first have to ask you what are you doing
in the negotiating room get out of there
go do your homework
but if you have to negotiate with little
information and let's face it sometimes
we have to
then to avoid lowballing yourself go
second
summer experts suggest that it may be
wise to counteroffer quickly
to offset the anchoring effect of the
first offer
alternatively you may want to adjourn
quickly and then
go do some research but conversely
if you're negotiating and you do know a
lot then
in order to avoid being anchored you may
want to make the first offer
the challenge of anchoring and
lowballing raises two questions
i get quite a lot from students what do
you do
in an early job interview when the
interviewer asks you
how much do you currently make and what
are your salary expectations
as you probably can see this is a
dangerous
question first because it asks you
in effect to anchor yourself by
mentioning a number at the start of the
discussion
worse it asks you to in effect low ball
yourself
since that number is often low often
you're looking in part because you hope
to make considerably more in a new job
and let's face it it's also irrelevant
what difference does it make
how much you currently make what really
matters is what are the market rates for
the work you will need to do
in the new job for all of these reasons
the question is an example
of a killer question a question which
you answer at your peril
if you answer a killer question you can
seriously [ __ ]
or even ruin your ability to negotiate a
fair and favorable agreement
so what do you do following most experts
advice
my basic suggestion is this don't answer
that is find a gracious and polite way
to deflect the question
in the job interview case you might say
something like this
well with respect i find it's best to
defer conversation about compensation
until i more know more about the duties
and what's fair
but i'm confident that when the time
comes we'll have an excellent
conversation and work out something
that's satisfying for everyone
but what if the interviewer insists
that's an increasingly likely
possibility
so here's a fallback approach i would
recommend you might say something like
this
okay since i understand that the
question matters a lot to you
than to show good faith i will of course
answer it
i just ask respectfully that we agree
not to use that information as a
benchmark later on
but that we rely on market data and the
like
this way you can later remind them
politely that you won't let them
use your current salary to anchor the
conversation
but what should you do about the
question what are your salary
expectations
if you can avoid it by simply saying
you're negotiable
and that you'll consider any offer read
any reasonable offer then please
do if they press and demand numbers
try to offer a broad range adding that
you'll know better what's appropriate
as you learn more about the job and the
market
being a person with ethos also feels a
lot better
than trying to outwit the other person
manipulation is exhausting
and emotionally draining yes it takes
more preparation to come up with
creative options that satisfy both
parties interests
but if you do that work you're more
likely to come up with a deal
that both parties want to keep and
you'll probably have an easier
conversation
first you prepare if you've prepared you
will feel more confident
going into the negotiation you will know
whether an offer is fair or not
because you will know the objective
criteria out there to compare it to
you will know what your walk away
options are so that you don't feel
compelled to do a deal here if it's not
going to be a good one
and you'll have taken the time to write
out
questions which makes it more likely
that you will remember to ask them
i have found that always staying
professional and calm
is a powerful tool in a negotiation
even if the other side is coming at you
with guns blazing
you can change the dynamic and even
improve the relationship
if you stay reasonable and fair by
managing your own emotions
you can impact the emotions of the other
person
it works the other way too if your
partner is upset and you respond by
being
upset then you're going to ratchet up
the tension and it might be hard
to ever find a mutually agreeable
outcome
but if instead you can show yourself to
be a person of in aristotle's words
good common sense good moral character
and good will you may find that your
negotiating partner begins to exhibit
those same qualities as well
at the end of the day a negotiation is a
great opportunity
to connect with another person to learn
about his perspective
and to create a relationship it enables
you to come up with a solution
that you couldn't have put in place on
your own
and it's another great opportunity to
practice your skills of persuasion
[Music]
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about any of the topics in
this episode
the full list of series that these clips
came from is in the description below
you can watch all the full series now on
onedrive.com and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel
turn on notifications and you'll get an
alert every time we post a new episode
of perspectives